celebrities are getting themselves into
trouble as we end the year James bondar
Pierce brosman is actually heading to
court in January he's accused of
trespassing in Yellowstone National Park
the actor allegedly stepping off the
trail and into the very dangerous
protected Hot Springs area he was then
slapped with two violations and The Rock
just got busted for apparently Lying by
fans of a popular Burger chain Dwayne
Johnson taking a social media to say he
has never experienced the iconic
California restaurant in and out before
we have three double doubles lettuce
tomato onion no sausage instead of the
spread what's a
spread oh yeah yeah no no no spread
anywhere The Rock must have a bad memory
he's already been to the fast food joint
at least twice in the past six years and
even documented eating it and the reason
why this is history in the making is
because this is the very first time that
I have ever tried an In-N-Out burger or
In-N-Out fries or anything from In-N-Out
for that that matter now I picked up
some In-N-Out Burger before uh through
the drive-thru a few times for some
buddies of mine I've never tried it so
this is a
first straight to the slammer right
Jimmy well here's where I absolve him
okay he might have forgotten eating it
because here's a news flash Inn out
overrated oh no I thought you were going
to say in and out quickly and you don't
remember it thank you no what well hey
girl no what a burger is better than now
I'll take water burer in my Tex chain
for the wind but take it a step further
okay the one thing you can penalize him
for okay is anyone in Hollywood that's
eating anything deserves a round of
applause okay I'm friends with Hollywood
actresses when they get pregnant they
start eating for one okay the fact that
we've even gotten some calories into a
Hollywood body is a wiip yeah especially
in the age of Olympic right where
nobody's hungry um yeah do well so first
of all when we talk about fast food on F
Fox and Friends Weekend they always
bring us the fast food so I'm waiting
for the In-N-Out Burger to come um no
In-N-Out burger here uh I think he's
obviously going through to get paid a
paycheck for this right I mean he's he's
doing this this is a way it's a
promotion for sure by the way on the
Pierce Bren thing I am officially
volunteering to arrest
him is he your favorite I do think he is
so darn sexy and age has not affected
him at all and yeah and and he's still
married to the same woman and I I just
everything about him is look at that I
mean and he just kissed me I do think he
should me a
Kissel I do also think he should be
arrested but for what he did I can't
stand it when people go off the trails
at National Parks into areas they not
supposed to go and he took a big risk
because these Hot Springs are like 10
they're dangerous yeah 80 degrees they
can actually literally cook you so
stupid idea but at least he didn't do
get too close to the Buffalo but how is
I mean anybody who watched Remington
steel can't be surprised you did not you
probably you probably we're aging
ourselves Charlie Remington steel is 20
years older than her like I'm not
kidding like legitimately W like I
remember when it was coming out when we
would watch it because we didn't know it
wasn't like binge watching what does
that have to do with breaking the rules
of Yellowstone oh just but that that he
would have like gone Outside the
Lines he's a celebrity the don't app he
would applied it to a movie well I think
it goes ways but I think it falls into
that category where sadly where selfie
deaths happen it's kind people go I'll
go stand by the cliff or I'll take a
picture with a lion you know there's a
lot of in a weird way addition by
subtraction because of social media you
got lucky you can get swallowed up by
those things but also how do I mean who
sends the rock to go pick up uh your
order from fast food in and out out in
and out said go through Burger and and
we're talking Charlie he wasn't working
for GrubHub he was going to get it's not
clear I don't understand any of that it
sounds like he's lying he's he's exactly
and he wants to run for office and so
he's already you know starting to lie
yeah there there you go he's got that
under his belt now he does can I just
give Pierce broen a break on one thing
and I want to just cut off Jessica one
more time I love you I know you have a
lot of great things to say the reason I
can't begag on broen is I come from a
long line of terrible tourists my mom
she needs to be called out for this
maranne fa got kicked off Elvis's plane
at graceand because she got so excited
when she saw Elvis's bed she jumped in
it and alarm went off and an alarm went
off my horny mom got dragged out of the
plane got thrown off the Lisa Marie and
there's nothing I could do to like talk
the guy out of it it just had to take
the L man sorry he's the king for a
reason hurt you should watch Priscilla
oh it's good yeah it's beautiful um and
his bed is featured in it heavily is it
ever with them in it okay up next a man
and his paintball gun vers hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else